mon invité a une carrière brillante dans
le privé après avoir grandi dans une ZEP
de Seine-Saint-Denis élevée par des
parents immigrés mais un événement
inattendu est venu bouleverser sa vie et
l'engagement politique est alors devenu
une évidence pour elle
[Musique]
bonjour Prisca théveno bonjour alors le
grand public vous a un peu découvertes
si on peut dire au mois de janvier 2020
quand vous avez été nommé porte-parole
dans marche et depuis une grande partie
de votre travail politique on va dire
consiste en ça là vous nous parliez de
la réforme des retraites
laissez-moi vous expliquer vous allez
voir je vais vous dire très clairement
oui nous devons revaloriser les pensions
minimales de retraite oui nous devons
prendre en compte les pénibilités oui
nous devons prendre en compte les
carrières longues moi je vous dis
simplement qu'il faut augmenter l'âge de
départ à la retraite pour pouvoir
financer cela
donc vous avez compris vous pourrez le
répéter à nos camarades donc là c'est un
parfait exemple vous passez une grande
partie de votre temps à défendre
l'action du gouvernement l'action de la
majorité ici à l'Assemblée sur les
plateaux télé on vous voit ici face à
Jean-Philippe Tanguy lui tenir tête vous
vous laissez pas déstabiliser et
pourtant j'ai lu que vous vous
définissiez comme timide et sensible on
peut être porte-parole comme ça de la
majorité et être à la fois timide et
sensible oui je pense qu'on peut l'être
en tout cas je le suis donc je vais pas
me réinventer je suis profondément
timide et très émotive mais ça veut dire
que c'est une souffrance pour vous de
faire un plateau télé comme ça ça
pourrait l'être et en fait c'est devenu
une force ma timidité m'oblige à
extrêmement préparer mes sujets ça veut
pas dire simplement relire des fiches et
des notes mais aussi aller confronter
ces sujets avec mon entourage ma famille
proche bien évidemment tout d'abord mais
également les gens de mon quotidien le
boulanger la boulangère mais également
les professeurs les parents d'élèves que
je croise vous forcez votre nature un
peu vous êtes nombreux
je m'oblige à me dépasser à me surpasser
et je pense que c'est comme ça qu'on
avance c'est-à-dire ne pas rester sur
nos acquis sur nos facilités et quelque
part on continue toujours à apprendre
tout au long de notre vie et ça je pense
qu'il faut qu'on s'en souvienne en tant
que politique on va resituer un peu les
choses dans leur contexte quand vous
êtes nommé porte-parole vous êtes simple
militante en marche vous avez aucun
mandat vous n'êtes pas députés vous
n'êtes pas élus comment on devient
porte-parole comme ça d'un coup propulsé
sur les plateaux télés ça s'apprend vous
avez une formation vous avez été non pas
du tout et je dois le dire je me permets
je suis toujours une simple militante il
se passe juste que j'ai une mission vous
avez un peu plus de bouteilles vous avez
vous êtes habitué à être confronté à des
adversaires politiques à débattre avec
eux bien évidemment n'aviez jamais fait
avant je ne l'avais jamais fait par
contre débattre on le fait toujours
depuis le plus jeune âge nos enfants
viennent et essayer de débattre avec
nous pour nous convaincre de certaines
choses je le fais maintenant peut-être
de façon plus officielle plus affirmée
et devant plus de personnes non il n'y a
pas de formation et j'ai envie de dire
la meilleure expérience qui soit c'est
celle de la vie c'est d'être en capacité
de se dire qu'on ne sait pas tout par
défaut et qu'on va apprendre et qu'on va
apprendre surtout pas tout seul mais
avec les autres et pas seulement celles
et ceux qui pensent comme nous mais
surtout ceux qui ne pensent pas comme
nous et je pense que c'est peut-être là
la meilleure école de la formation alors
pendant longtemps vous êtes resté
éloigné de la politique on peut le dire
vous avez une carrière brillante comme
consultante dans les dans les télécoms
et puis un jour est arrivé ce que vous
espériez sont plus trop y croire vous
êtes devenus maman oui c'est vrai
[Musique]
en réalité en réalité merci pour le
portrait que vous dressez mais en
réalité j'ai une un parcours d'une
banalité extraordinaire et c'est
peut-être ça qui fait qu'aujourd'hui je
suis peut-être de temps en temps une
députée qui sort de l'ordinaire parce
que j'attache une grande importance à ma
famille bien évidemment mes enfants mes
deux garçons que je ne cache pas qu'on
voit assez souvent mais aussi mes
parents mes parents qui peut-être m'ont
appris la chose la plus importante c'est
qu'on pouvait tout perdre et on pouvait
tout nous enlever sauf peut-être quelque
chose de fondamental c'est l'éducation
alors du point de vue de ma mère ça a
été l'éducation par les livres aux
parents qui sont nés qui sont nés l'île
Maurice à l'île Maurice et qui sont
venus en France par amour de la France
qui ont vécu pleinement leur amour et
oui je vous disais ma mère c'est par
l'éducation par les livres donc elle
prenait des heures carrées à faire du
temps avec mes devoirs reprendre mes
leçons etc c'était vraiment une chance
et puis mon père c'était pas l'éducation
par les livres c'était plutôt
l'éducation par la vie il travaille de
nuit et souvent j'attendais qu'il rentre
parce que j'étais un peu et quand il
rentrait vers 3h 4h du matin j'allais
arriver discrètement dans la cuisine et
je le voyais avec tous les journaux
étalés parce que lui me disait c'est
bien d'apprendre ce que beaucoup de
femmes beaucoup de grands hommes ont
fait dans les livres mais intéresse-toi
à ceux d'aujourd'hui ce qu'ils font
aujourd'hui pour toi pour moi pour nous
demain et je pense que ça a été
éducation elle est importante là vous
nous parlez de l'importance de la
famille pour vous qui est fait partie de
votre engagement en tant que député
aussi l'engagement politique moi je en
fait si je me suis arrêté sur la
naissance de vos enfants c'est parce que
vous avez eu cette phrase vous avez dit
j'ai voulu me lancer dans la politique
par envie de faire évoluer le monde dans
lequel mes enfants allaient grandir
c'est la naissance de vos enfants qui a
été le déclic de votre engagement
exactement et exactement et c'est pour
ça que je parlais parce que ça a changé
votre vision du monde ça m'a obligé en
fait pourquoi je vous parle de mes
parents parce que ça s'inscrit dans
cette démarche là celle de continuer à
évoluer et celle de continuer à
s'inscrire dans le monde dans lequel on
est on est il s'avère et c'est vrai que
j'en parle très rarement mais que
pendant très longtemps tout au long de
mon adolescences on a dit que je ne
pourrai pas avoir d'enfant pour
différentes raisons médicales je ne
pourrais pas être en mesure d'avoir
d'enfant donc je me suis attachée à
vivre mon existence pour moi et moi-même
bien évidemment pour mon entourage mais
sans penser à ce que je laisserai
derrière moi peut-être égoïstement vous
me le direz mais le jour où j'ai eu la
chance de tomber enceinte d'avoir mon
premier enfant et puis mon deuxième
enfant et bien je me suis dit non là il
faut que je m'engage un peu plus et
c'est là que je me suis effectivement
arrêté de travailler bien évidemment ça
se fait pas comme ça ça se fait aussi
grâce à un homme qui est mon mari qui
m'a toujours soutenu et accompagnée donc
là vous arrêtez votre carrière dans le
privé vous créez une association pour
venir en aide je crois aux jeunes mamans
qui reprennent de travail après un congé
maternité et puis l'engagement politique
arrive un peu plus tard en 2017 avec une
rencontre décisive pour vous c'était le
30 mars 2017 à Saint-Denis
alors je vais vous parler pour être
original d'éducation et d'accès au
marché du travail mais en se mettant
dans les baskets d'un jeune du 93
pourquoi je j'estime que je suis
légitime pour parler de ça ce soir parce
que je suis moi-même fille d'immigré
j'ai été élevé dans le 93 j'ai fait ma
scolarité en zette à ce temps plus
précisément et avec ce profil là je vous
laisse imaginer les quelques difficultés
que j'ai pu rencontrer on parlait de
votre timidité tout à l'heure je suis
désolé mais quand même faut pas mal de
culot pour prendre la parole comme ça en
public devant un candidat à la
présidentielle qu'est-ce qui s'est joué
pour vous ce jour-là
si c'est joué ce jour là en réalité je
ne devais pas être là déjà
j'ai j'avais entendu parler de cette
organisation de manifestation qui se
passait pour les jeunes talents des
quartiers moi je ne vivais plus dans le
93 mais effectivement je suis une enfant
du 43 et puis par hasard m'a dit bah si
tu es là vas-y va écouter c'est
l'occasion d'assister à une de ces
réunions publiques c'était un peu le
format grand débat déjà à l'époque
c'était en 2017 et puis j'entendais les
uns passer après les autres puis d'un
coup ça m'a pris je me suis dit il faut
que je lui demande il faut que je lui
demande en fait pourquoi lui on doit le
croire pourquoi lui on doit le croire
tes candidate au législatives dès 2017
alors à l'époque vous avez été battu
mais vous êtes resté engagé au sein d'en
marche de façon bénévole et en plus de
cela vous avez créé 6 villes impacts
alors expliquez-nous un peu ce que c'est
civil impact tout simplement c'est que
je suis partie du principe que moi
j'arrivais de plein fouet dans un monde
qui n'était pas le mien le monde de la
politique où il y a des codes et ces
codes si on veut un peu les briser un
peu les renverser ce qui est un peu mon
objet et bien il faut quand même les
connaître sinon c'est compliqué avant de
s'en affranchir il faut les connaître
bien sûr c'est la base et donc le
principe c'était de dire six mois je
pars de postulat là d'autres aussi et
c'est faux de dire qu'on va en politique
comme on rentre au McDonald's
excusez-moi de la comparaison mais c'est
un peu ça donc il faut pouvoir s'engager
et créer cet univers cette communauté
auquel on peut à laquelle on peut
appartenir et sur ce principe là je
pense qu'il y a un exemple qui est très
bon en ce moment et qui moi me guide
depuis un certain nombre d'années
maintenant c'est la première ministre de
nouvelles Zélande jassinda Arden qui a
décidé de se retirer qui a décidé de se
retirer mais avant de se retirer elle a
décidé de s'engager et elle a décidé de
s'engager d'une façon très étonnante
c'est à dire qu'elle a qu'une seule
règle finalement celle d'en finir avec
les règles du monde politique celle d'en
finir avec cette vision de la politique
qui veut qu'on soit plus puissant qu'on
soit en permanence en train de montrer
les muscles pour être dans un bras de
fer contre tout surtout et en permanence
quelque part elle assume qu'il y a
peut-être une faiblesse peut-être la
plus belle des faiblesses que nous
devons mettre au centre de notre action
politique c'est la faiblesse du cœur
cette faiblesse qui nous permet d'avoir
une action raisonnée passionnée mais
surtout audible et qui embarque et elle
nous rappelle peut-être l'essentiel et
c'est ce que j'essaie d'expliquer dans
civil impact mon école d'engagement
c'est que finalement on ne doit pas être
attaché au pouvoir en tant que politique
on doit être surtout attaché à notre
devoir celle de faire mais surtout celle
de bien faire non pas pour nous et pour
celles et ceux qui nous ont donné une
mission est-ce que derrière cette école
il y a aussi l'idée que vous voulez
faire bénéficier d'autres jeunes qui
sont peut-être issus du même milieu que
vous qui sont confrontés aux mêmes
obstacles leur faire bénéficier un peu
de votre propre expérience
il s'agit simplement de dire venez à
prendre l'engagement il est faux de dire
que l'engagement est facile et il est
inné l'engagement est difficile il est
compliqué alors ça prend justement
l'engagement est difficile moi je me
suis arrêté sur cette phrase que vous
avez prononcé engagez-vous mais faites
attention l'engagement est dur ingrat il
faut pas hésiter à temps de la main en
cas de coupure l'engagement ça peut être
ça peut être vécu comme une souffrance
aussi c'est dur c'est dur mais durant
quoi c'est je vais pas je crois que
j'invente rien et je ne suis prendre je
surprendrai pas grand monde en disant
que oui c'est dur c'est compliqué c'est
parfois très complexe surtout quand on
est une femme et on est maire de famille
et qu'on ait vu comme un peu jeune
est-ce que c'est un surmontable non à la
seule et unique condition qu'on accepte
de pas être seul qu'on accepte de tendre
la main cette main c'est pour aider les
autres mais aussi pour de temps en temps
demander de l'aide allez c'est l'heure
de notre quiz je vous rappelle le
principe je vais prononcer le début
d'une phrase ce sera à vous de compléter
cette phrase être une femme députée
c'est plutôt
c'est plutôt complexe c'est plutôt
complexe c'est exactement ce que je vous
disais avant c'est que en plus d'être
une femme député je suis une maman
députée et donc ces rock n' roll souvent
c'est passionnant toujours et je pense
que c'est une force vous voulez dire que
c'est le regard des hommes politiques
sur les femmes politiques qui peut
encore poser problème aujourd'hui non
c'est le regard du monde politique du
monde en général vous incluez les femmes
dedans bien sûr je pense qu'il vous
savez moi je suis pas de celle qui dit
que les femmes sont par défaut dans une
sororité absolue ce n'est pas vrai et on
doit être capable de le dire aussi bien
sûr que nous sommes bienveillantes les
unes avec les autres mais il faut aussi
affirmer que il y a beaucoup de femmes
pour pouvoir exister dans ce monde
politique ont dû faire comme les hommes
et donc on reproduit certains schémas il
faut pouvoir casser cela on poursuit
notre quiz depuis que je suis député ma
famille me dit souvent
mange mieux ah il se préoccupe de votre
santé il se plaignent pas de vos
absences non parce que je suis alors
j'étais déjà avant dans le privé quand
je travaille en privé pas souvent très
présente mais c'est vrai que je fais
attention à avoir des moments un peu un
peu sacré où je suis présente mon
téléphone exactement et je suis là mais
oui c'est vrai qu'on a des rythmes
infernaux et que du coup je mange quand
je peux et ce que je trouve donc c'est
pas toujours très bien dernière phrase
entre porte parole on se dit souvent
écoute c'est à dire oui on est là pour
parler pour expliquer pour peut-être
mieux à prononcer certains débats sur la
sphère médiatique mais il faut qu'on
apprenne aussi à écouter
c'est la fin de cette émission une
dernière question sans que vous êtes
passionné par la politique pour vous cet
engagement il est là pour la vie ou
c'est une simple parenthèse vous savez
encore une fois on ne sait pas de quoi
demain sera fait
je me projette je me projette le plus
loin possible en tant que femme en tant
que mère ensuite l'avenir me dira
j'étais salarié je suis aujourd'hui en
politique je n'étais pas censé être mère
je le suis aujourd'hui on verra merci
beaucoup Prisca Thévenot d'être venu
vous confier dans la politique et moi
merci
[Musique]